- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC: Social Scene
is based on your suggestions
from made up Ultimate
Frisbee moves.
- [Voiceover] To sport is human,
to win divine.
Welcome to Sports five for five.
- It was one of those
moments where you just know.
This isn't a game
anymore, this is a sport.
This is Ultimate Frisbee.
I remember I was
playing with Joe,
and we were getting
into it, you know?
And then, Joe said something
I'll never forget.
- I was like, this is cool, but
what if we made this cooler?
What if we made this ultimate?
(techno beats)
- The Frisbee had been
around since 1938,
but it was a toy.
Daryl Derbin and Joe
Butters looked at that disc
and saw something revolutionary.
- Basically, they
played Frisbee, but
they got real into it.
I mean, they would
throw it really hard,
or do crazy throws.
They invented crazy throws.
- A lot of those moves
are still used today.
The Flippity.
- The Handful of Disc.
- The Spinner.
The Crash Helmet.
The Teapot.
- The Clothesline Tackle.
(groaning in pain)
- They would throw the
Frisbee while running.
- No only did they throw crazy,
they started
catching crazy, too.
- Unnecessarily
complicated catching.
And then they did something
that nobody saw coming.
They played Frisbee
against other people.
(chanting "Go Blue")
(screams)
(players yelling they're open)
- Oh, look at that!
Nope.
I mean, before us, it
wasn't even a game.
It was just a fun
activity you do
with your family and
friends, you know, boring.
But, we took that fun activity
and we made it into an intense,
no holds barred, winner
take all competition!
- People would be like,
"Don't think think you're
taking this too seriously?"
And, I would be like,
"I think we're taking
this way too seriously!"
(shouting and cheering)
And, then it got big.
Real big.
(inspirational music)
We made the cover of Disc
Weekly, the Frisbee Journal,
Spokane Quarterly
Farmer's Almanac.
And that's when Jenny
joined the league.
- Joe and I felt that
Ultimate Frisbee would be
too dangerous for a lady.
We were wrong.
(sultry guitar solo)
- Come on! Come on!
(screams)
Yeah, yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah!
Watch it!
Yeah, you know my mom
wanted me to get married,
have kids. (scoffs)
I was like, "Yeah right, I
gotta throw that Frisbee!"
Is it you or me? You decide!
Me! Me!
This table came natural,
and you know what?
It worked.
Oh, yeah!
- And, this is when
things got really crazy.
- The celebrity, the
fans, the need to win.
(cheering)
It was too much.
- And, like all good things,
it fell apart.
- Darryl and I got caught
up in a tampering scam.
(police siren chirps)
- I told you, it's not my glue!
It's not my glue!
- Let's go.
- I want my lawyer!
- They would put crazy
glue on their hands
so the discs would stick better.
It was a clear and frankly
obvious violation of the rules.
And, out of respect for
this sweet game that I love
more than anything,
I had to punish them.
- You get addicted to winning.
I mean, I couldn't stop.
(somber music)
I'd hit rock bottom.
I'd wake up with
glue on my hands.
And, that's when the league
came down hard on us.
- It was the decision of
the league that the sport,
as it stood, was too ultimate,
and steps had to
be taken to make it
less ultimate.
- They were out.
The guys who started the
whole thing, just like that.
- You know, I didn't
want them to go, but
the game had changed.
And, they cheated.
- Sure, the game is
still played today but
it's not the same.
It's not as ultimate.
- Sometimes, life
throws you a curve ball.
But sometimes,
sometimes
life throws you a
Frisbee. (chuckles softly)
- [Voiceover] Join
the conversation now
with CC Social Scene
tell us about your
weirdest family member,
and we might write it
into our next sketch.
Presented by Redd's Apple Ale.
Pick different.